Let's consider a network of SDN switches, such
as open flow switches and a controller that
is controlling those switches, and let's assume that
we would like to write a program using this
interface. We can think about this programming as
proceeding in three steps. The first is that the
controller needs to read, or monitor network state,
as well as various events that may be occurring
in the network. These events may include failures, topology
changes, security events, and so forth. The second step
is to compute the policy based on the state
that the controller sees from the network. This is
effectively what we talked about last time, is the
role of the decision plane. In deciding what the
forwarding behavior of the network should be, in response
to various states that it reads from the network switches.
The third step is to write policy
back to the switches by installing the appropriate
flow table state into the switches. Consistency
problems can arise in two steps. First, the
controller may read state from the network
switches at different times, resulting in an inconsistent
view of the network-wide state, and second, the
controller may be writing policy as traffic is
actively flowing through the network. Which can
disrupt packets along an n to n path,
or packets that should be treated consistently because
they're part of the same flow. Both reading
and writing networks state can be challenging because
open flow rules are simple match action predicates,
so it can be very difficult to express
complex logic with these rules. If we want
to read state that requires multiple rules, expressing
a policy that allows us to read such a state can be complicated
without more sophisticated predicates. For example, let's suppose that
when we are reading state, we'd like to see all web serving traffic except for
source one, two, three, four. Simple match
action rules do not allow us to express
such exceptions. As a solution to this
problem, we need a language primitive that
allows us to express predicates. Here is
a simple statement that has several predicates;
such as, and and not. A runtime system can then translate these predicates into
low-level open flow rules, ensuring that they
are installed atomically and in the right order.
Another problem that arises is that switches only
have limited space for rules. It's simply not
possible to install all possible rule patterns for
every set of flows that we'd like to monitor.
For example, if we'd like to count the
number of bytes for every source IP address, and
generate a histogram with the resulting traffic, we
would potentially need a flow table entry for every
possible source IP address. It's simply not
possible to install all of these possible rules.
The solution is to have the run
time system dynamically unfold rules as traffic arrives.
A programmer would specify something like a
group by source IP address, and the run
time system would dynamically add open flow rules
to the switch as traffic arrives. Thereby guaranteeing
that there are only rules in the switch that correspond to active traffic.